our next guest made fashion history as
victoria's secret's very first
australian angel but these days
she's an accomplished businesswoman as
the founder and ceo
of her organic skin care brand cora
organics please welcome miranda kerr
[Applause]
oh my gosh i'm good you know as i'm
sitting
and doing my homework and seeing all
that you have going on and with this
year
and you know you had your one child and
and then you have your second child and
now you have your third child
and it's 20 20 and everybody's trying to
take on so much
how are you real talk like how are you
handling it all yeah it's um
it's a lot to balance with my company
and my three kids because i am still
breastfeeding my one-year-old
and i have a two-year-old and then i
have a nine-year-old who i'm
obviously homeschooling right now so you
know it's
it's um a lot to manage but
i'm doing it i mean does it ever like
look and
feel super hairball like i'm having one
of those
days a little bit where i'm just like i
feel like i'm on roller skates
like on a very greased floor i'm just
like oh my goodness i'm trying to like
you know keep it all together and it's
not always
easy i know it's definitely not that's
why
you know just like taking a breath and
bringing it back to
the moment like exactly where you are so
that you don't feel like you're too much
into like what's going to
be happening next you just write where
you are and it's definitely something
that requires a lot of practice
yeah i have the word um breathe actually
tattooed
on my wrist and
i forget to do it all the time i mean
i'm clearly breathing i'm alive but
you know did you find that side of
yourself
that wanted to be wise and zen
and clear and breathing when did it all
start for you
so yeah i grew up my grandparents pretty
much
raised me because my parents had me when
my mum was 17 and they're still together
so much very much in love which is so
cute
and my grandpa actually would bring
home for my grandma these big geode
crystals
because he would he was a house mover
and so that's where my love of
crystals came into it so he would bring
them back
and there was a willow tree that would
climb as kids
we had the crystals at the base of the
willow tree
and um and that's the thing that i
actually say now if someone told me once
that it's better to be
like a willow tree in a storm the willow
tree is so flexible
and bends and then like an oak tree that
people think and assume is so strong
is so rigid that it breaks in a storm so
i tried to tell like people on my team
from cora with my company let's be
flexible like willow trees
and go with you know whatever's
happening
don't fight against it yeah no
it's good to be more fluid and flexible
um and that's someone who literally
before this you know
morning started i was like this so i get
it i probably could have snapped in two
with like a a soft breeze i was
being so rigid i should get into my
inner willow
that's such a beautiful story what is
the difference between some of their
crystals and their meaning
yeah so the amethyst which i have here
is a great crystal for meditation and
also
sleep so i have a big one next to my bed
i'm actually at pisces i'm born in
february and
that's my birthstone um so i'm a fan
and i'm going to get a giant one next to
my bed exactly
then the citron is
a beautiful stone that actually brings
about
positivity and joy and self-confidence
well i identify with this rock
yeah i i like to be very positive
so with crystals so i'll talk you
through the rest of them that we have
here so the rose quartz
which is my favorite actually this is a
very
soothing calming um
nurturing crystal so this one is
all about supporting your heart and the
heart chakra
and bringing in that very humble
self-love
and kindness and so it's almost like a
big hug
is the way that i describe it so
all of my products from cora in the
manufacturing process
the crystals come out they get energized
by the sun
and then they go back into the big vat
and then all the ingredients
touch upon it and they're energized with
that beautiful loving energy of the rose
quartz
and actually i don't know if you're
aware but on the back of our products
there's also a positive word so for
instance on the back of our
tumeric two in one mask i don't know if
you've tried this it's a really good
exfoliant
but on the back it has radiant so a
positive word on the back of each
product
when we're using the products to remind
ourselves to get into that
positive state and like shift our state
of mind because
every thought we think really does have
an effect on our body
on a cellular level and there's been so
many studies done on that
oh gosh my body is probably like a
sewer then from some of my like
self-criticism
i'm going to work on that too